[Music]
how do you balance strength and
vulnerability strength and humility and
power how do you balance that stuff well
i love this question now and i like how
you explain it to me because
we are not meant to not be feeling i
think about it as parents yeah like if i
present myself to my kids that i never
have doubt i'm never wrong i'm never
sorry i'm never sad
which is a a lot of parents can do that
that doesn't make sense destroy your
children yes
and uh
at the same time if i wake up every day
and feel like you're responsible for my
feelings my sadness and everything else
and and those are the two extremes now
most of us think the first one is
actually pretty good though
like kids i'm fine
and and that's not i mean i kind of grew
up in an environment like that my dad
was like that and i didn't understand
what vulnerability was
and so i think the thing is we have to
say hey listen first and foremost i'm
here to serve you i'm your leader i'm
your parent i'm your whatever
i'm your coach
i am here for you
but i also have
legitimate valid feelings that i will
share with you
because that's going to make you a
better person to understand that i'm
human and to play the role of helping me
too sometimes that's right
i mean kids need to know they can
support their parents employees need to
know that they can speak truth to their
boss
athletes on a team need to know that
they can help their coach
whether it's in coaching or in life or
whatever it is and to deprive them of
that is not a gift right
so but the que the question we have to
know though is when in doubt it when in
doubt it needs to lean toward the
service to others as a parent my
feelings have to be just a little less
important than those of my kids but if i
try to do that for too long they're
going to pay the price for it i've done
that wrong for years
i thought my job was to prevent them
from suffering
and then it it wound me up and then it
caused suffering for them that i didn't
even know it was causing them yeah which
is hard to admit but so many parents i
talked to can relate to that so i got a
i got a call from
um somebody who i've known for years
who's
long story short that has a child who's
getting in trouble with the law and said
hey i could get a lawyer and do this and
do this and do this and maybe get them
off whatever
i said
are you interested in solving this
problem today or you're gonna help this
child become
a healthy adult
i said because if you're gonna help them
be a healthy adult then you say i'm like
i can't get you out of this but i'll
hold your hand in the process
and i'll go to court with you and hold
your hand
and when you get taken away i will be
the last hug you like that was and then
they'll do their time and then we'll go
about you know i mean that to me was the
though we're playing a long game with
their kids right right but and so i can
say this with fairly high confidence the
difficulty of making the right decision
there is because we're caring about
ourselves that's right yeah because if i
go so my son has to go to prison or to
go to jail or go to juvenile hall or get
in trouble it can be smaller than that
too
what does that say about me that's going
to be hard for me
i'll i'd like to help them get out i'm
going to be uncomfortable yes
and i and you don't even
completely realize at the time yeah but
if you can
the most self-less thing to do for them
is to give them what they need even if
it doesn't give you what you need
because i want to know that i'm being a
good parent i want to know that they're
they're they're happy right now yeah
yeah and they're going to be happier
when you get them out of trouble thanks
dad that was great and you're like oh
yeah they're happy with me i've just
kicked that can down the street
yeah and then when they're moving back
in with you or they're asking for a loan
yeah exactly yeah yeah all right so
leaders and vulnerability how does that
work
you know
it's one of the most important things
like so in the five dysfunctional team
trust is at the bottom of the pyramid i
mean you have to build trust on team and
the leader has to go first and you
cannot build trust with another person
if you are not
vulnerable
and and vulnerability is a powerful
thing but it has to be real
and false vulnerability is more
dangerous than not it's gross man it is
it's just like humility is great gross
false humility
is is great anytime somebody says hey
watch this you're going to cry i'm oh
i'm done with you yeah
yeah exactly oh so so vulnerable genuine
vulnerability which always
is uncomfortable yes
if you're being vulnerable as a leader
and you're like no i'm very comfortable
with this it's not vulnerable that's not
false because vulnerable gets killed
right that's the that's the whole thing
right really up yeah exactly
the the in latin it's it's it's
liable to attack
gosh what is that i can't remember the
the root of the word vulnerability but
the point is
every leader has to be vulnerable but
when they they go too far
and they they're using it as as therapy
yeah that can be very dangerous too yeah
and so it's one of those
um
it's one of those maturity things it's
like parenting though no leader is
immune to this there is no leader that
never did that yeah
and there's no leader that's never
probably been falsely vulnerable we
don't have and i'll say politically
i think that may be the single
missing element
is a leader saying
i thought this and i was wrong so here's
what i'm gonna do
if somebody would do that i think it
would galvanize people in a way that
that you couldn't even plot on a chart
in a graph i do not under maybe it's
maybe it's this john maybe it's the kind
of person that wants that job
does not have that that
skill or that capability because the
kind of person that would be willing to
do that would never do the things you
need to do to get that job
but i don't know why people just don't
say because i mean i've done it yeah i
have to hey i whiffed on that yeah
most people will say a coach that comes
off the field at the end of the game
goes i made a hugely bad call there yeah
yeah and we lost because of me people
are like that guy's awesome follow that
guy yeah yeah but somehow in politics
it's bizarre
yeah you know what i mean it's but it's
bizarre i think they're being advised by
people that
i don't know it's it's such an
adversarial activity i suppose it's like
a lawyer though i i guess if you went to
trial not too many lawyers would go hey
i said this thing yesterday i think you
should disregard it because i realized
that wasn't fair oh yeah and i think
when you have an adversarial
relationship no but the problem is
that's why politics is not leadership
politics is gamesmanship
and true leadership two too few
politicians are really leaders
and i've met a few that are yeah they
usually don't get anywhere near the top
huh because they're not playing they're
not playing and if you're if you're
competing with somebody who's playing by
a different set of rules and you tie you
tie one hand behind your back because
you want to be that way they're going to
go that's great i'm just going to cut
your arm out you'll lose every time yeah
so it's an unfortunate thing i don't
know if it's always been that way i
don't i think media makes it worse
absolutely um but i do wish we had
leaders in leadership yeah would that be
so nice all right what about leaders and
mental health
well this is my this is my the thing
that's most interesting to me right now
is that so many leaders are leading from
their wounds
and they don't even know that
they actually see
their wounds as their strength
i mean i did this for years you know i
was achieving and at high standards and
worked hard and i thought well see i'm a
hard working guy and it's like oh no
you're terrified of failing huh
and that doesn't mean you can't heal
those wounds and still be a great leader
in fact you'll be a much better leader
and so i think that uh
i think mental health of the leader is
critical how do you balance that
humility with ambition
because it feels like a teeter-totter
and what i see people is
they'll go they'll be making their money
they'll be doing a good job they'll go
to their spiritual retreat and they'll
be like oh i'm going to quit everything
and go work at whole foods and
or you have the other side that's just
pounding the pavement over and over and
there's got to be a balance between no
go like work hard and do good things
that help a lot of people
and no it's not going to i don't know
what's the balance there well it's so
funny i wrote an article
23 years ago yeah
um and it was called the trouble with
humility and it's this teeter-totter and
it's like here's how i look at it and i
don't know if this answers a question
but i just have to tell this story
and it's like humility is i think that
i'm no more important than the people
that i lead okay right that's really
important to know you're not that you're
not a more important person
but
my ac my actions
are more impactful
than those of the people i leave people
are watching me and that's truth that's
just true truth that's right and most
people can't hold both of those things
in mind at the same time i worked with a
guy who was a really humble leader and
i'd say mark you got to get out there
and talk he'd go why do i why do they
care what i think
and then other people that are like hey
i got out there and i inspired people
and then it's like
i must be pretty important uh i'm more
important than them so you have to break
that in the middle and go my actions
actually are that stewardship you know
that's really but i'm i'm not that
important that's a tough thing to do
both of those i used to tell my staff at
the universities i worked at
if i didn't come to work for two weeks
as the senior student affairs officer if
i didn't come to work for two weeks
a couple of y'all would know
if the person cleaning the bathrooms
doesn't come for two weeks this place
stops spinning period right let's be
real clear about who's the most
important in this building right now
right now you can never lose that but as
the leader you know what was really
important that you were telling them
that oh yeah yeah you know what i mean
so that was really important that you're
so you have to do both of those things
that's right yes and um and then you got
to live it right i got to make sure that
we are honoring the the folks that are
left in the margins at that workplace
right oh my god that's that and i've got
to i've got to go first and whether i'm
a parent or a dad you want i i did an
internship with a or with a psychologist
and i was asking him a question about
hey how do i how do i tell my son to
respect women and he said respect he's
like yeah treat your wife right it was
like it's like you can tell anything you
want he's just going to watch you but
what would be another way yeah
yeah not that way yeah it was a very
simple i was with my 15 year old this
the other day we were in a long drive
and i said
hey you know i love mom right
and he was like oh yeah i said because
you know sometimes we don't say that i
sometimes i don't treat her the right
way and she might not she might be
unhappy with me but you know we're in
love with each other and she's wonderful
and because
i don't know i never heard my dad say
that yeah yeah yeah and i needed it yeah
and and god bless him and my mom but
but we we have to model that and it's i
think parents we don't understand that
our kids anchor
everything into that sentiment yeah
are those two people stable and safe
and if they are the kids will swing off
and rappel off and do wild things
and if they aren't they will swing off
and do wild things but they'll let go
you know they let go and you know if uh
if people are listening to this and they
haven't done that very well in the past
you can just do it right now and trust
god that it's going to be fine well it's
that's vulnerability which is you know i
had a guest on a few weeks ago and we're
talking about
is is vulnerability or is it humility
it almost
rests on a bedrock of as you put in the
book it's just being trustworthy being
honest saying
i've been telling you this and i was
wrong this is the right way to do this
or do you know how i treated mom for a
few years there not good bad not good
and you're going to watch me do better
right yeah uh because i know when people
hear things like this it's easy to go oh
i didn't do that well and it's like no
start now what's that old adage what's
the best time to plant a tree ten years
ago yeah exactly or today second second
best is today that's right yeah
you